it's great to be joined on the program
today by Neil Valley who's a lecturer in
sociology and Rutherford Foundation
research fellow at the University of
otago New Zealand I hope otago is the
right pronunciation Neil uh the the
latest book is futilitarianism
neoliberalism and the production of
uselessness I really appreciate your
time today
oh thanks David thanks for having me so
maybe to start with
futilitarianism I think many of us could
Intuit we're talking about there is
something futile about the way we've
organized much of our economies and and
the world and society and culture but
what what did you what do you mean by
the term
uh yeah so by the term it really came to
me as in in the process of writing the
book
um the book initially started out of a
series of uh protests against
um cuts to Humanity's division at my
University and I originally started
thinking about
um it was really like the the kind of
futility or the uselessness of the
humanities within the kind of
contemporary University structure the
way that it's constructed is useless so
if you do Humanities or Arts you can get
a job so on and so forth but then I
started the more I looked into that the
more I started to realize that this idea
of uselessness of futility
can spread out much further into kind of
everyday life in the 21st century
um and so where I got to a
futilitarianism basically is
is many of
um many many people might have heard the
word utilitarianism
and on a very basic level utilitarianism
is
that you maximize utility for a degree
that's good or the greatest number so
each individual
um
every decision they make they maximize
their own utility
and this should lead to a kind of
majority happiness yeah and basically my
argument utilitarianism is that we got
to a point now where each individual is
trying to maximize their utility that
might be by getting an education and
getting further training you know um
getting into debt to start a business or
so on and so forth but in doing so it
actually leads to the degree of
unhappiness of the greatest number
because we're an entirely individualized
atomized so it's a kind of inversion of
the utilitarian code
um and this is the state that I feel
like we know live in that the more we
maximize utility the more it leads to
the to kind of deconstruction of of the
common common good
there's an inevitable sort of interplay
here between the concept of
utilitarianism the capitalist systems
that to differing degrees most uh uh
modern what we might call Western
countries although the term Western is
maybe not the the right one
neoliberalism as well it's hard to get
out of including the sort of media
culture and the way in which
most people are learning about the world
so to speak all of these things seem
completely interrelated and maybe one of
the things that has changed or maybe has
become evident is that the preferences
and path that one increasingly takes is
less self-directed than we might imagine
and really more prescribed by all of
those other systems that I mentioned
yeah that's a really interesting point
actually and it's the kind of one of the
great kind of contradictions of the kind
of neoliberal period is that everything
is about you know personal
responsibility
um self-care
um picking yourself up by the foot
straps and making the most of your own
life and yeah as you make the point as
that actually the decisions that we're
making supposedly as kind of free uh
individuals are actually prescribed to
us that there's a certain structure in
place that forces us towards certain
decisions so for instance as a small
example I talked about the University at
the start there
um is that the way that universities are
constructed particularly across the you
know the global North is
is towards kind of getting a degree that
can get you a job
so if that's kind of rhetoric that comes
out from you know kind of public
discourse from media and so on and so
forth most most individuals that and
looking at University through that land
and so they make decisions on what they
study based on
um you know can I get a job at the end
of this that seems on the surfacing an
individual decision right and yet it's
entirely prescribed within this kind of
structure
um and I think this is an effect of
neoliberalism and I think more recent
studies of neoliberalism have started to
tease us out and initial studies of
neoliberalism are often about the kind
of um uh you know that it was all about
the kind of free market the rollback of
the states
um individuals who are kind of free to
whatever they wanted free to operate
highly liked in the market but more and
more we've come to realize there's some
brilliant studies of neoliberalism is
that actually neoliberalism isn't about
the rollback of the state it's about a
very different form of State
intervention and the role as a state has
become to encase the market to protect
the market from democratic decision
making and the new the early neoliberal
thinkers often talked about this
um at the Walter lipmann colloquium in
1938 where it was kind of first big
meeting of the neoliberal intellectuals
in Europe
um and they talked about the liberal
thinkers of the 19th century
um as opposed to a kind of new a new
liberalism and neoliberalism and for the
19th century left a fair kind of free
market liberals they used the analogy of
a road
um and they said if if there are no
rules on the road essentially people
will just keep driving into each other
they'll crash and so on and so forth so
what they they saw neoliberalism as a
kind of Highway code almost that you set
the rules of the roads and people can
drive when people are driving they're
driving to where they want to go they're
seemingly making individualized
decisions but there's just over
um arching structure that guides the way
that they drive and that's how they
envisage the market economy in a
neoliberal society if not everyone go
for their life do whatever you want it's
a there's this overall structure that
guides people in a certain way but
people still feel like they're making
individualized decisions but it's
actually Guided by a certain method a
certain structure
when in the book you write about the
useless and repetitive behaviors that
can become a trap of neoliberalism
absent any context what I would imagine
there would be one sort of story that
fits that is you go to school to get the
job and then you take out debt to get
the car in the house and the credit card
and you get a slight raise so you take
on a little bit more debt and it's sort
of like this endless rinse repeat and by
the way you're you're basically buying
the stuff that media messages tell you
you want or you should want or whatever
the case may be is that one of the
mechanisms that you're talking about and
what else did you mean by it
yeah very much so so that's certainly a
good example um and I you know I work
with with lots of students
um who are kind of increasingly
wondering what is the point of what I'm
doing here you know they look at their
for instance their parents generation
and we might have gone to University
particularly say here in New Zealand
they would have gone to University
um for free and also would have been
given us you know a scholarship so they
would have been paid essentially to go
to university and now these these
students are coming out they're paying
Masters fees to go to universities
they're all getting into debts to do so
and then they come out the other end in
that to a kind of depleted job market
where a house the house market is
absolutely crazy you know in New Zealand
the average cost of house at the moment
is a million dollars
so you know kids coming out with that
much stats are not going to be able to
afford to buy houses so there's this
kind of sense that all the things that
we're supposed to do all the things that
we've been kind of told will will lead
to a kind of good future for us are
suddenly crumbling you know you if you
go to university and get a degree you're
supposed to come out and get a steady
job and be able to kind of live you know
be able to get a house to be able to do
all the things that we associate you
know in the kind of Western or Global
um the global North as kind of
a a a good life suddenly none of these
things are available and so many people
are in debt and they're getting more
debt and so on and so forth and it's
this kind of endless cycle and yet we're
completely trapped and doing the same
things over and over again there are no
no way it seems like there's very little
few ways to get out of of that trap of
thinking this is what I have to do I
have to go to university or I have to
get through further training I have to
do so on and so forth to live this good
life in the future and the more we do it
the more things like our Collective
economic and social conditions get worse
and that's the Trap I call in the book
this utilitarian condition we get stuck
in this kind of endless trap and there
really aren't I mean genuinely there
aren't that many ways to completely get
out of that right I mean when we think
about them there's there's the idea of
the total off-grid life where you
essentially leave leave modern society
as the case may be you have to figure
out a way to meet your basic needs and
to really do that without touching the
standard kind of corners of the economy
that you're talking about it's
extraordinarily difficult another one
would be well you do it in a hyper drive
way for a short period of time such that
you make enough money that then you
could exit in a sort of different way
yeah I I don't I mean it's it's
genuinely quite difficult to not be part
of it at all
yeah yeah very much so and and you know
in the in the introduction to the book I
make a distinction
um between futility and annihilism and I
think
they're like they're the example you
used of you know going off grids and so
on and so forth It's a sense that you're
right like there are a few options the
only options we have are to try and
escape from it a very few people can
yeah you might be able to move off grid
but then you're kind of outside of
society yes level you can't you can't
influence you can't
um shape the way the world runs you just
and that to me is a form of kind of
almost like a passive nihilism it's like
I'm accepting that this world that we
constructed is meaningless and I'm gonna
sit outside of it yes and then there's
more kind of active forms of nihilism
though like example you use is that you
you go hard you you try and invent
something you do and so forth but even
even entrepreneurs I guess like the kind
of Silicon Valley entrepreneurs are are
trying to exit from contemporary
capitalism they're trying to get beyond
the kind of mundane kind of existence
that Mo like the majority of people have
to have to live in so there's two forms
of exit there but those exits don't
actually do anything about changing the
kind of fundamentals of that society
that we're mostly stuck in and the
reality is for the vast majority of us
no matter what kind of situation when we
have to we only have the kind of
structures of society that are available
to us and we have to somehow make the
best of that and it seems like that's
getting harder and harder and harder and
there is of course a kind of
generational politics in that you know
we're increasingly we're seeing that I I
kind of new class politics emerge in the
21st century or basically people that
own property and particularly housing
and people that don't and that often
Falls in generational lines and for a
younger and this book often I I do say
in the introduction of this book is a
kind of is a kind of Requiem for a sort
of doomed youth in many ways it it for
it's for a kind of younger generation of
the world that they're emerging into
and so it seems that there's the
question of how individuals can choose a
different path but then there's another
question of how can Society be changed
such that the default path is what
changes and it seems I mean are there
any actions that can accomplish both or
is it really you have to decide I'm
going to be within it completely but try
to change it or I will try to exit
personally
yeah I I feel like the former is our
only real option and and so I make a
kind of a a call in the book but we need
we need to turn essentially to one
another that actually especially on the
left you know
post 1989 poster fall of the Soviet
Union that I that the kind of there's
been a kind of and and inherent sort of
distrust in the left of collectiveness
of collectivity
um I think particularly probably up
until the 2008 crisis and I think since
then we've seen the return of you know
particularly in the US or in the UK
parts of Europe of kind of democratic
socialism
the idea of of a kind of collective
subject of a collective political
subject
um and then in the conclusion of the
book I I construct a kind of I guess
it's a theoretical idea of this
collector subject and I call it the
futilitarian and it's oh it's it's a
kind of rest for uh um a development of
the prokaryote so the precarious is
obviously a kind of destroys a whole
group of people who exist in kind of
precarious lives whether or not they're
working conditions or even just their
living conditions
and there's also these people aren't you
know like the traditional idea of a
union which I think is also extremely
important and there is definitely a
Resurgence of a union there's something
you know people at work in the same
conditions and they share the same lives
in many ways certainly the same working
life the precarious actually a more
disparate Collective subject it can be
people working in Uber drivers but can
also include you know casual lectures at
University people who's who don't who
are living in kind of precarious
conditions and for me the futilitarian
is like an extension of that it includes
the people who live in precarious lives
are in precarious situations
but also so many of us who actually on
the surface looked like we're in quite
secure conditions still experience this
deep sense of futility in what we're
doing
and I feel like actually this shared
experience of futility across different
scopes of social life can actually be
the thing that can that if we recognize
it in one another we can use it as a way
to to build a kind of political a
collective political subject that can
actually confront
um the kind of the way the world works
if if we accept if we'd see
um our if we see fertility in one
another and we go actually I experience
this form of futility and of course some
people experience much more extreme
forms of utility than others in the same
way that some people experience much
more extreme forms of precariousness but
that doesn't necessarily mean we can't
somehow recognize it in one another and
try and realize and I think part of the
problem with contemporary capitalism and
particularly it's neoliberal mutation is
that we're we're expected to see
everything
as a reflection of our failures
essentially so anything that doesn't
work anything we end up in debt we we
can't get a job so it's because we we in
some way are brokenly somehow I haven't
um haven't done the right thing
and what I really want what I'm kind of
pleading really in the book is to see
that actually these experiences of
futility are not personal defects
they're a completely logical
um experiences of the kind of capsular
system in which in which we live today
the book is fascinating and slightly
depressing but only in the way that gets
you to really think about things uh the
book is futilitarianism neoliberalism
and the production of uselessness we've
been speaking with the book's author
Neil Valley lecturer in sociology and
Rutherford Foundation research fellow at
the University of otago New Zealand
really appreciate your time and your
insights today
well thanks so much David